dans l'une de ces boîtes se cache
peut-être l'objet de collection tant
recherché alexis lafreniere premier
choix des rangers de new york en 2020
n'a pas encore donné un seul coup de
patin dans la lnh mais le québécois fait
déjà courir les collectionneurs en quête
de sa carte e recrue tout le monde
cherche la fameuse carte de la fresnière
fait que c'est ce que j'essaie de
trouver juste aller chercher du paquet
pour essayer de l'avoir de la fasciner
but d'avancé arnaud larue était de ce
qui faisait la file avant l'ouverture
pour se procurer ces boîtes de la
nouvelle série de la compagnie upper
deck en espérant mettre la main sur la
fameuse carte numéro 201 sa page
spéciale parce que c'est un genre qui
aimait quoi vraiment sorti je pense que
non 200 paquets on n'a jamais eu autant
d'appels qui a pour réserver des bois
l'engouement déjà grand les
propriétaires de la boutique ont trouvé
une façon de mousser les ventes
il offre 10 mille dollars à quiconque
mettra la main sur une version très rare
de la carte de la première la version
réglos tiré à dix exemplaires seulement
c'est un gros prix mais on pense que
c'est peut-être une carte qui pourrait
avec les années le rendent à vannes oc
devenir un bel investissement à long
terme d'une carte de wayne gretzky quai
on pense heureusement au dessus d'un
million le mot prochain donc on n'a pas
de comparer pour la famille mais on sait
si une belle carrière après quelque
chose qui est qui pourrait valoir une
fortune à jour 1960
si ces cartes permettent aux commerçants
de réaliser de bonnes affaires
la pandémie de façon plutôt inattendue a
aussi donné un élan au monde du web et
les voyages définit les cinémas est fini
des restaurants stephenie alors les gens
sont tous riches d'un gris somme
d'argent dans leurs comptes de la banque
un récit à nantes il n'y avait jamais eu
depuis longtemps alors le les gens sont
virées vers leur hobby maintenant dans
quelles mains tombera l'une de ses
cartes de tant convoité
seul le hasard le dira on sait jamais il
si j'en fais des parterres radio canada
québec